at auckland airport hugs
tears
and a traditional maori welcome
for the first time in over two years
visitors from more than 50 countries
including the uk can once again visit
the country that had implemented some of
the world's most severe pandemic
restrictions
it'll provide a financial boost to this
tourism-driven economy and an emotional
boost for the families and loved ones
separated by the border rules
it was about three years between when we
saw each other we met in japan and uh
you had already come back to new zealand
when we decided to make a go of it
romantically and uh
could have planned better
over two years now we
started dating online 2019 and supposed
to get here
may 2020
and border closed so
been ready since then
a little bit more back to normal yeah a
bit emotional that's what i like to
imagine
precovered around 3 million people a
year visited new zealand from the
countries which are now back on the
welcome list accounting for 20 percent
of its foreign income and around 5
percent of its total economy
in the early hours of this morning we
marked another big moment in our
reconnection with the world with our
borders reopening to visitors from visa
waiver countries in addition those
holding existing visitor visas from any
country in the world can also travel
here from today of which we know there
are over 500 000 who fit into this
category and we welcome them too
because not only is this a further sign
of normality returning in our
interactions with the world but the
arrival of our northern hemisphere
friends will further propel our economic
recovery
tourists will still need to provide
proof of vaccination and a negative
covert test before being allowed in and
most travelers from india china and
other non-waiver countries are still not
allowed to enter
fraser moored sky news